what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we admitted to the final
episode of tales of the Jedi they have
all been great of course joined by
Michael burrito today
Michael
Omni media
you looking forward to this you ready to
cry
we'll see we'll see I am looking forward
to it not we'll see that we'll see if I
cry gotta close actually a few times
Well if you don't cry then you're you're
not giving a real reaction
it's the mark of true reacting
use the force to leave a like hey follow
Michael on his YouTube channel he's got
a great reaction Channel and also uh
full length watch songs will be single
they don't copy for Tales the Jedi
available at our patreon page thank you
all have joined let's get to it
poetry arrives
[Music]
oh wow
after Clone Wars after Revenge of the
Sith
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh wow
so cool is there
she wasn't
you shouldn't have come here
kind of crazy beginning epilogue here
why risk it
she was my friend
if you need anything you can contact me
with this
I'm tired of fighting
hmm
what can I do for you officer wow she's
just like Batman at this point dude I'm
afraid no one's allowed back
forgive me it's easy to get lost with
all that has happened
still
we have a duty don't we he's talking to
her
when we're able
we'll have to escort you back to the
procession Senator yeah I don't know
what you're talking about
yeah
okay you've added too much to drink
[Music]
be cool to edit this on to the final
episode
yeah I mean that would be cool
resolve you just leave me to it this is
my payload we're gonna break for lunch
foreign
them up too high I know what I'm doing
Oh I thought she would force it I I
thought so too
[Music]
oh maybe she did she did yeah oh yep
[Music]
it's like a niche it's like Magneto and
X-Men apocalypse a child
foreign
[Music]
s that Communicator through all of their
skulls
[Music]
I swear if they turn her in
Palpatine brought peace
through persecution
not citizens like us only Rebels who
threaten the empire
No One Is Safe
only if you aren't loyal is this guy we
are safe yeah
but not because of the empire
[Music]
good thing nobody noticed that
big freaking wink right here we have to
take the Harvest over to mon hella
tomorrow that path can be dangerous is
your brother coming along
no but we'll be fine won't we
master
Chef oh my God
I saw you push the Bales clear
ER you have it wrong
there's nothing to tell because of your
brother's attitude
and your eagerness to just
do this at first like
this is how people end up like Clem
yeah
oh God damn it
I heard her whisper Master Channel now
remember don't accept the first price
they offer you I know
don't worry
wank
Rebels dumb May the force be with you
I mean people say that but that you
[ __ ] such an antagonizing way yeah by
Ahsoka May force be with you
don't forget your lightsaber
bleeding is dry I couldn't get half what
they offered us last season
what the hell
oh what oh
no way
okay all right I thought it was
I find
see what you [ __ ] get dude I I should
be rewarded
who's this guy
he's an Inquisitor but who
let them go
she's the Jedi stop it see I told you
they'd be back you're gonna get killed
man so you did
you
are lucky
I'm gonna soaky little badass
[Music]
you're supposed to be dead
[Music]
[Laughter]
silicon tunnel
[Music]
wow
holy [ __ ] that was awesome
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry you're going to have to
leave how
where
Rick's
Baylor Ghana
oh thank you yeah
I was beginning to think you lost this
are you sure you're ready to get back
into the fight
ah neat
no
[Laughter]
it's like the freaking dark night music
yeah man
well I mean there was a lot of Batman
parallels in this episode what was this
dude's name
that Inquisitor I wonder if it's in the
credits at all
there you are just Inquisitor Clancy
Brown Nancy Brown though
he was so cool and he went out so quick
and he was also Clancy Brown was I'm
sure he's voiced other characters in
Star Wars but he was also uh he was part
of
forget the character's name but it was
in the Mandalorian the the first Bill
Burr episode he's part of that gang he
was the guy who looked like Satan yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's cool
I was cool that was cool that was really
cool I mean now it showed the Journey of
how she got back on the path that segues
the the in-between for Rebels right
there oh that was neat I figured I like
uh maybe maybe it's because of when this
releases but like it
because Andor is fresh in my mind yeah
just like the what was it the
in this last episode where they were
kind of talking about how like the uh
the the the Empire's like clinching its
fist so slowly people aren't starting to
notice
yeah that whole theme I kind of like
that in this and we kind of see it a
little bit here and there in bad batch
but for sure where you know we got these
people were like hey they're bringing
peace there's the Empire security and
all this stuff you know good YouTube
bringing in the good stuff you know
while their orders and the demand and
all this that they're expected of these
workers is
getting like incrementally harder for
them to achieve
as they were talking about is like they
we're not meeting the quota they want
from us and he's like that's fine it's
fine and then he was like
hey
uh Empire police I gotta I got you I got
you one of them Jedis thinking
everything would be fine and dandy
uh is that the first time we've seen an
Inquisitor in this animation format
um
I think so I mean obviously Rebels but
that was its own very distinct style
exactly that's what I mean like in the
Clone Wars style yes I think so looks
cooler
it does
like that that their helicopter blade
looked way better at this too yeah
I love that too like it just
it pays off to that training I think too
just like her reaction to be able to
disarm him without even a saber at that
point just shows like
how much of a Survivor she's become
well how far she's been pushed it's an
interesting parallel like before we
start filming anything you're saying why
you were interested in this of the
parallel of Dooku coming to a village
and then saving them but that
contributes to his dark path and then
Ahsoka
not exactly the same thing but there are
similarities and
then that leads to her fighting back
against Darkness
um yeah once again
I mean I think it's their
disillusionment like
they both experienced it but they
responded in completely different ways
well complements it and also the
backdrop of the fire
like her emotions at the time
uh yeah I thought that was really well
done I thought it'd be a little bit more
of a direct some type of connection
between her and and Dooku that they were
headed towards in some way yeah I
thought so too or like like for me the
Dooku stuff is definitely the more
compelling interesting part of this
whole journey but I'm not bitching about
the Ahsoka Tano stuff that stuff was
still really cool and it's just great
any any little bit more yeah look it is
great so um I I was all for it I thought
it was really strong still like the Duke
yourself was just a lot more it was like
the dark [ __ ] it was really compelling
you know but uh while that last episode
of Dooku I think like really kind of
supplants itself is like this
supplementary episode that can kind of
add some context to the films and such
um overall I felt like it like as a
narrative it it was able to his
three episodes kind of told a story
together
while these do thematically they feel
more like
add-ons definitely yeah like the Clone
Wars yeah in a way like Bridge into
maybe like her role in Rebels and stuff
like that so it you know I don't know
does that make sense yeah no I like it
with uh in terms of any little add-on or
addition to character stuff like I I
enjoy you know like it doesn't feel
a hundred percent necessary but it's
nice to know
look at these that's the kind of my mind
like it's nice to know and and I thought
I thought it was great so let's get a
little bit of an epilogue I know she was
at the funeral too uh for people yeah
for Padme was great
um yeah I thought it was still worth it
and and in some ways necessitates itself
and uh yeah I thought it was awesome so
and and yeah that I think it does go to
serve the purpose too like what you were
talking about with with and or and the
kind of the brother having just this
sold on this belief that no they've
actually been good
and to show that no there's they are
truly something evil I just started
craving lays salt and vinegar chips
haven't had those in years
and I just found myself this I could
taste it
like specific craving for that
um but now these these are all awesome I
thought they were all great and
I had a very enjoyable time watching
this with you and having this intimate
via Zoom experience with you Michael
we'll we'll have to make it more
intimate when I can make my way out
there yeah because my eyes never go to
Virginia
the hell's going to be in Virginia for
me to do
nothing exactly boreville out there
am I gonna go to the roller rink
what do you guys do in Virginia
's like going Trails
yeah get up nature who needs it who
needs nature mountains I got television
here man I can watch that at home I
could put it on the background while I'm
editing
so no man thanks for thanks for inviting
me on and doing this is the conversation
just kind of turned into a little idea
I think yeah I think uh I don't know I
I'm happy we did this one together I'm
happy yeah this is I hope you enjoyed it
otherwise you would be by yourself
like how everyone feels that way in
Virginia
oh lonely
all right well Michael
my white version of me go follow him
it's an inside joke if it's left in one
of the earlier videos I don't know
got all kinds of footage it's probably
gonna be cut out
um
go follow Michael Omni media and uh
thank you all who joined us on this
journey
this was fun
we'll see you all soon
take care May the force be with you
[Music]